foreign
hey you guys movie retrospective once
again and we're doing another really old
one because like I said we wanted to do
more you know stuff from kind of the
Golden Era because we had really kind of
been neglecting that so we got around
finally to doing cat people from 1942.
yeah and you had never seen this right
no I think I had seen it once or twice
like a long time ago I hadn't seen it in
many years but it was on HBO Max so we
went in there and watched that and I
kind of feel like the history behind
this movie is really interesting because
what they ended up doing and this is
weird because the movie I think is
really associated with Val Luton
obviously who was you know one probably
one of the most influential movie
Producers like of that era but the weird
thing about it is that he didn't direct
this I mean it was kind of like he sort
of co-wrote it I guess but usually
um you know directors get most of the
credit for the movies but in this case
it's usually like the producer her
because it seemed like he was a lot more
involved in the whole process than
producers usually are
but uh Jacques tornu tornurer I'm sure
I'm pronouncing that wrong but uh but he
was the one that directed it and they
worked together a lot
so basically what ended up happening was
that uh Val Luton had worked for uh
David O S Selznick you know very famous
guy and RKO pictures at this point were
having some financial difficulties and
it was mostly
um Orson welles's fault because he had
made Citizen Kane and he had made the
Magnificent Ambersons and both of them
while you know amazing films and
everybody looks back on them as Classics
nowadays but we're not real uh
profitable no uh thing is is that I
wouldn't put it all on Orson Welles you
also got to put it on Howard Hughes well
I'm you know I was really just making a
joke about so I could get into talking
about Howard Hughes was running RKO into
RKO pictures as a [ __ ] personal
dating service really he didn't really
give a [ __ ] about making money with RKO
but uh
yeah and and
[ __ ] Hell's Angels also [ __ ] over
RKO Pinterest it was a movie about World
War One Pilots but RKO pictures
was did come up with some really great
flicks okay
but uh RKO was a [ __ ] uh what do you
call it
Prestige project really for just Howard
Howard trying to date girls but uh you
know
then this movie came along a good movie
well I mean the thing about it like I
said so Orson Welles had made these
movies and even though as I said uh
there were Classics nowadays like back
then they weren't didn't really make any
money and archaeo RKO was actually going
to go under
so what they were thinking about doing
they said hey look at what Universal is
doing over there with all those monster
movies let's do that
so because prior to this I guess they
didn't really even have like a horror
you know Wing or they didn't have like
any you know or you know a group that
was doing horror
so they decided to start doing one and
they said we're gonna do what Universal
is doing so they asked Val Luton who at
this point I don't really think had
worked on I mean obviously he worked
with David o'selznick but he hadn't made
any movies of his own so they asked him
to head up their horror Division and
they basically said we're just gonna
give you the titles and 135 000 which
wasn't a lot even back then uh and you
are gonna give us a movie and kind of
make them like the universal monster
movies
so the first title that they gave him
was cat people
and they kind of wanted something like
you know like the Wolfman type of thing
now Val Luton was just kind of like yeah
but he's like I kind of want to do
something like that but he's like I'm
kind of more interested in making
something kind of more like classier you
know what I mean like not so much like
the universal monster movies but kind of
along the same lines so he had actually
written I believe a short story that was
called the bagita and he was also kind
of like looking into all of these older
uh kind of stories like other short
stories and stuff like that that were
kind of about cat people
and he's like I kind of want to do
something with that because they don't
really you know they have a lot of
werewolf movies and [ __ ] like that but
they don't really do a lot of stuff with
cats so he decided to uh write that and
it was him and you know the other uh
screenwriter and they kind of like
collaborated on it so they make the
movie or they start making the movie and
like the uh the executives I guess like
from the you know movie studio from RKO
kind of came over and they were looking
at the [ __ ] and they were like
uh we don't like this we don't like what
you're doing uh there's not enough
horror it's supposed to be a horror
movie and they just were not having it
and they were actually like threatened
to fire them and all this other kind of
crap but they persevered in the end and
basically made what Val Luton and the
director Jacques Turner wanted to make
and interestingly even though the
executives hated it it did go a little
bit over budget I think it ended up
costing 180 hundred ninety thousand
dollars which again was nothing because
I think like uh the movies at Universal
was making like Wolfman and stuff I
think they were one or two million each
so uh so they were really not expecting
all that much however this movie when it
came out was a massive success actually
sold out some uh theaters and like even
outdid The Wolf Man at some theaters
which kind of came out at around the
same time and ended up saving RKO from
bankruptcy it made four million dollars
which was you know like three thousand
percent uh profit yeah so uh at that
point they were like hey good job Val
and he went on to make nine more films
uh for RKO including like some other
really good ones like that one um with
uh the body snatcher with Bella Lugosi
and yeah Boris Karloff he made that one
uh I walked with a zombie which is also
great
but they kind of let him stay true to
his vision and more or less like all
nine movies that he made from there even
though they're not all considered as uh
as fondly as this one actually all did
make money and were kind of instrumental
and his movies like I said are very very
uh influential like became influential
like in the horror genre but probably
maybe not as influential as like
Universal but I kind of feel like
him and particularly the cinematographer
like the way that this is shot was
really influential and we also have to
bring up too that the uh the very famous
scene in this with like uh with the
woman like walking down the street and
then like it being quiet and then the
bus pulling up and you think it's like a
hiss of a panther or whatever like a
jump scare that was kind of the first
time I believe that was the first time
that had ever been done uh so now which
and now it's like in every single horror
movie where it's like quiet quite quite
bad you know what I mean but they had
never really done that before so for a
long time in the industry any kind of
like quiet quiet loud like jump scare
like that was called a Luton bus and he
actually used it again like in some of
his other films as well so it kind of
became like a little bit of a Hallmark
so that was like super super influential
as well
so uh so what is this movie about cat
people oh when we have to uh we should
probably do the Remake at some point too
I think the remake's better actually
well the Remake is more modern and it's
kind of more you know it kind of like
UPS the horror and honestly I think Paul
Schrader made the um the Remake which is
was in 1982 and he kind of based it more
off uh American Werewolf in London
whereas this one is more uh was kind of
like the idea was sort of taken from the
wolf man because she's essentially like
a werecat but um he wanted to make it
less a horror movie and more like it's
more like a Noir actually it kind of is
more yeah the original cat people from
1942 I kind of feel like it's more like
a Noir movie not not just in the way
it's shot but just kind of like I don't
know like thematically it seems more
like a Noir movie to me and a little bit
more like a drama that just has like
some horror elements to it you know what
I'm saying I liked everything about the
movie but the story
I mean it looked good had um good cast
um had filled with filled with uh 40s
hotties okay uh everybody's cute in the
movie even the even the girl even even
the overweight one with the cigarette
washing the floor was cute they kept
brushing and matches
she was like in two scenes yeah so
they're trying and the uh the set or the
setting is uh very like uh high brow
it's like a classy everything is uh uh
sophisticated looking I think the
settings were remade from uh were uh
reused from some Orson Welles movies too
because they said well they wanted it
cheap so they said we want to use us
sets we already got yeah so it's kind of
like uh taking place in uh in an
alternate universe where everybody is
[ __ ] fantastic and then everybody's
got a [ __ ] ton of money well it's
glamorous it's glamorous yeah which
that's what people pay to see people
like that all right because they want to
escape the drudgery of of everyday life
and they see a waitress working in the
damn restaurant and even she is elevated
in the movie so it makes you feel good
when you're a waitress working at some
dining here downtown giving everybody
chicken gumbo why is anybody eating the
chicken
yeah
which she was a comedic relief this
[ __ ] white ass mother keeps coming in
here
pie that's all he ever wants and I was
like that I thought that was like really
yeah though you tell
she's from Louisiana you tell these New
York people eat the damn chicken gumbo
it's good yeah but yeah then uh so
it's uh it was so that aspect of the
movie The glamor content uh it had good
effects there's a part where she's uh
having a dream and kind of hallucination
and there's animated cats walking
towards the the camera and there's a
swirling and then a cat man was a king
what's his name from King John from
Serbia from Serbia is coming up on you
and I was like oh that's pretty creative
that they used you know real high
quality hand-drawn
type animation
in a live-action movie to illustrate
like a dream or hallucination
um like I said certain parts of the edit
and everything were ahead of his time
like when the bus ends up giving you a
jump scare yeah that's like I said
that's the first time that that I've
ever had a lot of stuff in it was kind
of like important
but
the story had a bunch of potential in it
that they didn't they didn't do a lot
more stuff should have happened
it and it didn't
um she should have known that she was a
werecat a lot earlier in the movie and
then she should have gotten right with
it and then she should have killed some
more people and then uh she should have
uh [ __ ] had a slightly different end
uh to her I think other than what they
did because she kind of and that
character kind of ends abruptly and it's
ambiguous there's a bunch of stuff about
the movie it seems kind of like it was
pulling its punches like it could have
been a lot scarier it's not scary
no I don't think it's scary but but the
thing about it is that I think that Val
Luton specifically wanted to make
something that was more subtle than
Universal and wanted to make something
and honestly it seemed like the movie
was kind of more it was taking some
stuff from The Wolf Man because you know
like in The Wolf Man Like Larry Talbot
is a sympathetic character like he gets
bit by wolf and he gets turns out that's
not his fault so I kind of feel like he
was kind of playing with the same idea
here where Irina uh you know from Serbia
who she actually doesn't know she's a
werecat but she suspects that she's a
werecat because of like where she came
from and she fled her country and stuff
she just thinks um and it's not like a
full moon situation it's whenever you
get like sexually aroused or angry or
jealous or something like that so
anytime you have like really really
heightened emotions then you're gonna
turn into like a panther and so because
she's tried to like stay alone all this
time and stuff she doesn't actually know
if that will happen but she's like
really really scared of it so I kind of
feel like he wanted to explain blur her
as like a sympathetic monster because
you still like kind of feel bad for her
because she can't help being like that
you're led to believe that she was born
like that because they thought they
implied that her mom was there was a
wasted opportunity and earlier on in the
movie she goes to a Serbian restaurant
and everybody's all fantastic and they
got one fantastic looking woman in there
who's looking all like this and that
she's freaking out and she comes up and
recognizes her as another damn werecat
all right and she makes her a little and
there's like a little bit of Pookie
fighting a little bit like a Pookie
[ __ ] situation and then she walks off
and you never see that character again
she should have come back as a mentor
in this there's a bunch of [ __ ] that
they wasted that character should have
come back to her and said and since and
and confirmed to her that she was a
Pookie waiting to play
and then tried to walk her through it
you know what I mean it should have been
all kinds of stuff that could have
happened but they didn't they didn't do
it
um
it wasn't very creative writing so I'm
gonna go ahead and agree with the RKO
Studio managers and and give it a thumbs
down I would have thought that this
would have failed I agree because they
didn't like it I didn't like it either
they could have done some really cool
[ __ ] with it with with storytelling uh
there was a lot there they could have
done but they didn't do it
um and it's kind of like it kind of like
they didn't want to risk it or they
didn't want to pull it they were pulling
punches or like they didn't want to that
way they didn't want too many pookies on
the screen what's the problem the whole
[ __ ] movie was a Pookie fight between
the chicks
all right and a man that really wasn't
worth it worth it to be honest with you
and and uh like I said every every girl
in this is cute so why let's just go
ahead and lean into it make it a cat
fight over men
and which that would have made a lot
more sense to me I don't know I kind of
feel like seeing there they did make a
sequel to this which is called curse of
the cat people and um Arena does come
back like as a ghost or something and
she's actually kind of like
communicating with the daughter of the
the guy and the woman like from this one
you know but like from this one they get
married and then they have a kid and
then like she but it's kind of like a
slightly different thing
um but I don't know I kind of feel like
like I said I think that he wanted more
something and if he watched like some of
his later films like you kind of see
where he's coming from with it like I
said he was more interested I think in
exploring Arena like as a character and
was kind of interested too and you
didn't really see this a lot in the
1940s I have to say you didn't usually
see female characters like Irina that
were kind of like
I don't want to even call her a femme
fatale because she wasn't like vampy or
anything like that like I said she was
sympathetic like yeah she killed
somebody like at the end but one that
dude had it coming because he was a
[ __ ] sleazy creepo yeah you know what
I mean so I was like oh well but you
like I said she couldn't really help it
and the thing about it too that I
thought was interesting that I kind of
liked the whole like you have to go into
this movie like not expecting a horror
movie because I agree with you that it's
not really a horror movie it does have a
couple of scenes in it that were very
influential like for horror later on but
it's more like a drama with like a
little bit of horror element to it you
know what I'm saying um you know the the
bus scene and the pool scene which is
another one that's like really famous
which was actually like recreated
exactly like in the remake from 1982.
those are like were really influential
horror the look of this was influential
the look and I think that it's still
influential in the sense of horror that
tries to like not show things as much
because they think that what you can
imagine is like scarier than what you
can show on screen which I believe like
Val Luton was like a big advocate of
that like he didn't even want to show
the cat at all
um but then like the the RKO Executives
were like hey we paid for this Panther
so you're gonna put it in the [ __ ]
movie you know you know what I mean they
got these Panthers in these really
Barren looking cages on hard surfaces
walking around in public go man I I
[ __ ] hate that they used to do that
to cats and [ __ ] I think they probably
did because I bet I went to some zoos in
the 70s that still kind of looked like
that they could go indoors and there was
another thing they only had them out
there certain hours but then the guy the
custodian is like oh yeah those things
are deadly and evil you know they're
like something from Satan and then in
the same movie later on you see that
same Panther wrestling live action with
another dude you could tell it's a setup
that's just somebody's Pookie
they're kind of upholding them upholding
The Stereotype how vicious [ __ ] big
cats are and yeah people have been
killed by them in the wild and sometimes
they go eat in captivity [ __ ] gone
crazy
but you can nowadays with YouTube I had
we had no idea when I was a kid even up
until the 90s up into the 90s so [ __ ]
what those things were like
you can go on YouTube and see that there
are people that own them in their house
just walking around it's like the family
pets like having a big old dog getting
in bed I'm gonna go I am puma look at
that channel and [ __ ] Puma gets into
bed with that that [ __ ] Russian dude
in that [ __ ] Puma loves that man
[Laughter]
it's just
[Laughter]
daddy Here Comes daddy in that [ __ ]
Puma
you're home yeah so you know they're
raised around people and they're being
fed they just yeah and if you don't [ __ ]
with them yeah not [ __ ] with them
they're just like I mean in the wild
they'll eat your face off sure the
temperament of them is just like a
domestic house cat
um from what I've seen from the people
that own them the difference is the size
and this size Matters in the animal
kingdom once when shit's hungry okay and
if it doesn't know you
um well I've I've often said that if
pookie was it was our sister that side
she would probably absolutely eat us
well I don't know if she would eat us
specifically because we raised her right
if she was if she was in the wild yeah
and she was big depends on the situation
but we're getting a little bit off
talking I'm just saying that what else
is there just saying that you know
um the the size Matters in the animal
kingdom and so does hunger but
also Family Matters too you don't see
cats eating each other when they're
hungry so they just I mean the dad Lions
will eat the Cubs of like another that's
like that's control yeah that's just
because they're trying to bring the
females back into into here because he's
like hey these aren't my kids
we're gonna repress the reset button on
this because uh you're having my kids
next time you know it's that kind of
[ __ ] yeah and then I was thinking about
it it's Instinct they're just told to do
it you know I guess they can sense that
those aren't theirs or maybe not that
might just be that uh not you're gonna
give it up and you you know you're going
back into heat I'm sorry I'm sick of
this it might be that too because they
won't go into heat as long as they're
you know taking care of y'all yeah but
that's the thing I was kind of cracking
up like when we were watching the movie
last night and uh and Tom kept calling
them all pookies because yeah because
all the cat people and he's like oh my
God 40s Pookie fight you know what I
mean so I thought that was like super
funny but yeah but I actually really
liked like I said if you go into this
like not expecting a horror movie
because it's not necessarily scary but I
liked the drama aspect of it I
specifically like the kind of love
triangle that goes on between Irena the
cat person and her husband whose name is
Oliver Reed actually yeah um and uh he's
played by Kent Smith and his like work
like the this girl that he works with
this woman that he works with and kind
of she falls in love with him and blah
blah blah the weird thing about it
though and I didn't even think about
this while I was watching it but I think
I thought about it later because there's
a thing where I mean basically the dude
Oliver he meets her in a park like while
she's sketching the big cats right and
like literally five minutes later
they're buried I'm assuming that they're
it's like kind of going ahead in time I
missed it that's when they were at the
restaurant and the other Pookie came and
said sister like to her in Serbian that
was the wedding yeah okay that's or like
the reception I guess right and the
thing about like he marries her like
without
I mean I'm assuming consummate the
marriage well that's what I moved was
she told him and she told him ahead of
time she's like hey look man it's like
I'm really have all these fears that I'm
afraid you know she told him about where
she came from and all the fairy tales
quote unquote that are true uh you know
spoiler alert about like the cat people
and everything and she suspects she
might be one so he knew when he married
her that she was like I might not be
down with this sex thing because I'm
afraid I'm gonna turn into a cat and eat
you which you know fair enough she did
give him warning of that and he married
her anyway because he thought that she
was delusional yeah and you know and she
kept saying I need more time I need more
time I didn't want to fall in love with
you you know I wanted to be alone
because I was afraid this was going to
happen yada yada but he seemed like he
couldn't the weird thing about him was
that he seemed like he couldn't resist
her maybe that was kind of like the cat
people kind of thing because he didn't
really seem to know that much about her
like as a person he seemed to like the
work woman better yeah I didn't really
like her character that much I mean it
seemed she seemed kind of mopey and
whiny and it was drawn out a lot and it
was too much of her I don't know you
know yeah I don't know she
the the way it was edited and the way
the way that character was written I
know it's the 40s but it had to have
been tighter I think because it was it's
a short movie it's only an hour ahead
it's only an hour her dialogue seemed
repetitive to me
um the they they should have done
something with her uh cat wear cat
sister should have been involved in this
story uh
dude should have come up with this whole
thing about we have to do
the mature thing there's these doctors
that help people they're called
psychiatrists you know what I mean
[ __ ] like which is that some Cutting
Edge [ __ ] back in those days when we
need to take you to these things guys
called psychiatrists well yeah people
didn't talk about that but then the
psychiatrist turned out to be a sleaze
bag yeah he was trying to get in those
[ __ ] drawers man that's what I mean
and that's why when she turned into the
panther at the end of him I was okay
with it yeah I was okay because like I
said she nobody believed her she tried
to tell them this psychiatrist thought
all of her problems were all of her
problems was that she were due to the
fact that she had unrequited love for
him you know yeah he was super gross he
thought
the psychiatrist thought that she loved
it what would happen if I Kissed You
right now and she said I would not like
to be kids yeah
that's what he told you're just fooling
I know you want me I know you want me he
was all like that you're just lying to
yourself and MST fans that was the same
condescending douche that was in the she
creature I knew he was in some other Val
Luton movies too but so he he's like
super super condescending oh clever girl
he was like all like that and I was like
oh my God please eat him well she does
she does kill him he's not that he he's
he's not that obvious he he does kind of
he does to me it was he has a mirror of
[ __ ] being like real [ __ ] high
class and stuff and that he's
trustworthy but when you actually
analyze what he's saying no he's trying
to [ __ ] use his mental powers to get
in those drawers yeah but uh and it it
didn't work though
well no she turned into a werecat and
[ __ ] killed it then killed him yeah
and rightfully so well cause like I said
it's one she can't help it two she
suspected she was a werecat all this
time and told them that she suspected
she was a workout it's their fault that
they didn't believe her okay she can't
help what happened you know she's like
an animal I don't think she rightfully
killed him what are you talking about he
didn't rape her no but I'm just saying
he was just he just I just made a move
on her and just that says come on baby
you're not amazing she had bam but she
had told him but she had told him like
numerous times I said that was his fault
for not believing him yeah she couldn't
help turning into a werecat all you had
to do is just get her too riled up man
boom next thing you know yeah because it
wasn't just it's not just sexual arousal
it was also anger and it was also
jealousy because when her husband like
starts going and like falling in love
with the with the work with his work
colleague
um you know she obviously like Arena
gets jealous and starts stalking that
woman which leads to kind of that big
that uh scene where you kind of just see
the cat's Shadow like on the thing and
you hear her growling like when the
woman's in the pool so so it's not just
it's any kind of like strong emotion and
so it does really seem like her whole
life she's tried to like keep an even
Keel and like trying to keep on the down
low just in case like so she doesn't
turn into the [ __ ] but you know things
happen and then like I said it's you
know I'm not saying I don't know I I
maybe I am saying the like the
psychiatrist kind of had it coming
because one he was that he was just
creepy so if you're a creepy dude and
you try to date some chick she can kill
you that's what she's saying no it's not
no no no no no no no no no he just made
a pass no you're you left out a huge
thing from the context of this movie she
turns into a werecat if she can't help
it yeah and she warned him that that
would happen and I said so that's his
fault that he didn't believe her and
still tried to like mac on her anyway
after she won after she told him not to
he thought she was crazy that's what I'm
well that didn't that's what I mean
that's his fault I'm not saying that
like anybody like you deserve to kill
him unless you like really come on
strong yeah but I was like if that woman
has repeatedly told you that she's a
werecat and she's like yeah I'm afraid
that I'll turn into a werecat like if I
get mad or if you like try to like have
sex with me and he's like oh you little
childish idiot like you don't know
anything and then he still tries to do
it anyway and then she's like oh well
turned into a workout now you're dead I
thought it was some kind of neurosis
well he found out he was wrong didn't he
he thought it was well I think it was
you know so he thought it was some
Superstition from back in the honky
mother like yeah that's what her husband
thought too and he then he was also
wrong and that he can disprove it you
know he can disprove it like watch I'll
just kiss you and see nothing happens
you know what I mean and then yeah yeah
but you know he's trying to be logical
uh that that's kind of what it is well I
know that and but you know yeah he was
he was trying to Mac on her though too
yeah yeah after she told him that she
didn't want him to that's no reason to
kill the dude I'm just saying that it
wasn't Justified that say it's just that
she's a monster yeah and like I said she
can't help being a monster and she
warned them yeah no they should they
should okay they should have done a
bunch of other stuff with the story
though there's a bunch of a bunch of
wasted potential
with the story it wasn't quite
complicated enough not enough happens in
it
um
her character doesn't get fleshed out
enough
well she's kind of yeah she's seen as
kind of a mystery and I kind of feel
like too that
she's almost like a representation of
like
I don't know like it was kind of like
repressed sexuality I guess I I guess
they were kind of like coming from that
angle with her she should have killed
several dudes in the movie and several
women for different reasons
um she should have tried to somehow
overcome and control these abilities and
these powers and then eventually uh
somebody then she had she should have
had that other
a Pookie cat as a [ __ ] Mentor the
older Pookie yeah and then
um she eventually gets killed
um it really should have been she should
have been killed by her husband that's
she should that she should have been
killed by her husband defending the girl
the girl that he worked with that's how
it really should have ended if you asked
me I mean this now she got wounded by
the psychiatrist right while they were
fighting because she had like that cane
that had the blade in it and he like
stabbed her but like just in the
shoulder but then she just went but they
but yeah she just goes it's been work
with with a woman who was really more
his style they had the same profession
they worked in a [ __ ] building thing you
know what I mean which is showing you
inside office in the 40s where you got
draftsmen and drafts people working in
their drafting out ships and barges
which is in those days that was a
high-tech job man uh doing Drafting and
stuff here mechanical engineering and
stuff and it's showing you that they in
the movie's showing you that they had
women doing that and they were working
in that office well she was pretty much
like on the same I guess he was an
engineer was she also an engineer's what
they were saying I think that she was
off worked right next she worked right
next to him and doing the same right
stuff she [ __ ] actually laid it on
thick
that she that he need that that he
needed to uh that he has trapped himself
in this marriage that for the woman that
really he had nothing to come in common
with him yeah he says basically
basically he's like yeah I don't know
what it is she's just hot she's just so
hot I can't remember what he's saying
well that's what I'm saying I thought I
thought they were implying that because
she was a werecat that he couldn't help
himself because he seemed like I guess
he'd worked with Alice as the uh
co-worker's name like he had worked with
her for a long time and they were like
buddies and I kind of feel like she and
then she was in love with him and she
finally like admitted it but he seemed
so clueless yeah that it's like she was
right there like all this time before he
even met Arena and then he just meets
this girl like randomly in a park and
then he marries her and then later he's
just like what the [ __ ] I don't even
know anything about her I'm like well
should have ended after she killed a
bunch of people she's trying to [ __ ]
deal with this stuff and uh him and and
his work partner that girl that blonde
they should have gone to try to rescue
her from something to cops or whatever
and in when she sees uh when she sees
her husband with that other other uh
woman in a fit of rage she turns into a
dad where cat he jumps and tries to
terrify
and the husband kills the the panther
form
uh to save the the girlfriend the woman
he really should have been in love with
yeah see that's what I mean I don't
understand like yeah but like I said I
think the implication was that Irena was
because she wasn't trying to like me she
was just minding her own beeswax at the
zoo and then he suddenly like started as
hey and like flirting and everything and
she was just like hey great but then she
was like oh okay whatever but I I think
that because she had that CAT person
thing that he couldn't like help himself
it was cat pheromones that's what I'm
saying I think yeah I think that that's
what the implication was even though
obviously they couldn't come out and say
that because this is a post Haze Code
movie yeah his explanation
to to the other woman that he worked
with who was in love with him his
explanation to her of what it was that
why he was with her boiled down to I
don't know he just said I was drawn to
her that's what he said oh no that's
what I mean so I think it was like
sometimes it's just beautiful yeah I
just you know because like I said he
didn't really seem to know anything
about her really or be interested in her
as a person whereas him and the
co-worker seem to have a lot more in
common she was actually kind of thin in
in terms of character there wasn't much
to her well like I said I think she was
just supposed to be like mysterious like
a femme fatale kind of character but not
a bad person yeah you know what I mean
yeah she's a monster but she can't help
being a monster and she just seemed kind
of just vapid to me that character
didn't seem mysterious at all just kind
of vapid just a vapid kid you know she's
probably what 1920. I
think she's supposed to be like 19 or
20. and uh she had a badass pad I mean
she was just
she'd have to be from a super wealthy
family to afford a place like that and I
wouldn't what I guess was in maybe New
York or Chicago it's supposed to be New
York New York yeah although I'm pretty
sure they shot it all in sets because
like I said they were reusing uh you
know stuff on those from their lives
only only an heiress would live in a
yeah I mean that was a really really
nice place it's like super super
glamorous all right and I mean she was
supposed to be what like a fashion
illustrator writer that's what she said
anyway yeah which I don't think there's
a bunch of money and I don't think well
much more money in that so that means
that she had just a kind of like a toy
degree to give her some purpose uh an
excuse for uh saying that she was
educated but really when you're old
money it doesn't matter yeah maybe
that's what it was now because she said
now that she did say a little bit about
her past like I said she's been at some
Village in Serbia she'd escaped from
there she didn't know who her dad was
but that her mom now did her mom get
killed or they said that her mom was uh
was maybe a werecat or they or they
thought she was a witch or something I
don't know because I'm assuming that
that's she had to have gotten money
somehow because like I said which they
never mentioned witch yeah they did
Satanist
yeah I'm pretty sure they said witch too
though that they said oh they thought
she was like a cat person like uh or
whatever and that she was a witch or a
Satanist or something like yeah so there
was that but yeah I mean like I said if
you go into this if you like stuff from
the 1940s who like Val Loot and stuff if
you've seen like I walked with a zombie
and he did one called like Isle of the
dead and he did like a bunch of ones for
RKO this was the first one he did for
them and I like I said I would recommend
like not going into it expecting it to
be a horror movie like it's got creepy
scenes in it that were really
influential but it's not scary really
necessarily but it was actually like
really really influential and like I
said I'm kind of interested to see the
Remake again too now that we've seen the
old one because I remember really liking
the Remake but I haven't seen it in a
long time that was Malcolm McDowell and
Natasha Kinski right yeah and they
actually put them yes Natasha Kinski
that [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] right
there it's crazy sick [ __ ] had
hot daughters yeah yeah well apparently
he also thought so yeah or at least with
one of them but that's crazy yuck he was
crazy Klaus well yeah crazy but uh well
I think in the remake like I said they
made it more like American World in
London so it's like more overtly horror
but they also made it so that Natasha
Kinski wasn't the only cat person like
they made it
I'm not really sure why but they also
made Malcolm McDowell like her brother
right and he was also a cat person yeah
you see in the remake cat people
would only turn into the panther if they
had sex with a mortal human
okay but it wouldn't happen if they did
it with their own kind
but the only kind the only of her own
kind that was still around was her
brother right so you know how that
turned out
[Laughter]
right so you know and yeah and you're
incest yeah and evidently incest doesn't
matter between cats anyway that kind of
deal
yeah
now I kind of want to see that one again
too
because that was like I remember that
being like he basically lays it on or
he's like we you know because they
didn't grow up together
in in the remake yeah that's that's
right I forgot much later and she didn't
even know that she had a brother that's
right I forgot and [ __ ] he had been
trapped he tracked her down he was
looking for because he knew he had a
sister somewhere that's how I remember
it
and he basically he'd been looking for
okay that makes sense yeah
yeah and I guess you got sick if I can
turn it into a damn werecat every time
he's like man I'm tired of like having a
[ __ ] habit get rid of his body I know
it's like so I got this big mess to
clean up Jesus Christ it's really like
too much trouble I know can you imagine
well like I said if you're a cat person
that would be right that would really be
an inconvenience so it wasn't just me
saying this somebody else agreed that
the story is not it's not complicated
enough it would have been a lot better
see they had another werecat in this see
and then there was there was another
woman in this another love interest it's
just the story was not
enough
it looked good though it had some good
ideas and the
certain effects and the way things are
edited we're kind of ahead of its time
yeah I mean but it is very subdued it's
too subdued it is very subdued and like
I said that's up to the person like some
people still actually like really like
this movie
um I really like this movie but I agree
that it is very subdued and I wouldn't
go and I wouldn't call it a horror movie
necessarily like I psycho thriller drama
yeah I think it's like a drama Thriller
like with Noir and horror uh sprinkled
on top of it so I would call it I've got
a feeling that this probably did Super
well with female audiences of that time
I think it's a female oriented type
movie
the main characters are female and
they're actually good characters
especially for the time like they were
actually like pretty it's visually the
kind of movie that women would like
especially back then
and uh that's probably why it did so
well
and it's scary but not so scary that
would be turned off a female audience in
that time
so it'd be kind of like an accessible
horror movie for for female audience of
that time I think that's probably why so
so what they did was is they probably
inadvertently hit a niche market and
it's kind of a [ __ ] romance Motif see
which that would have been been niche
market right there boom and so they can
build a demand that they didn't really
know that they had yeah that's actually
a good point because probably you have
to think like the universal monster
movies were really popular but I kind of
feel like that was more skewed younger
and male and more maybe more male like
probably not I don't know like generally
but it was probably like a younger male
audience whereas like this one seemed
like it's kind of a horror movie but
like I said it was classy and it was
more geared toward adults yeah and was
more maybe geared toward a female
audience and like I said but the RKO
probably didn't even think that that was
a market that they could exploit so what
you're talking about is the 1940 for
1940s version of the Jack Nicholson
movie wolf
wolf was a was a was a werewolf movie
skewed older adult all right this this
was kind of like that yeah that's
actually like probably yeah that's a
more recent older adult more female
though more female audience for this one
wolf was for both male and female yeah
this one is more female I think so
other dudes can watch it I don't think
it's like girly girly but you know what
I mean but it is more focused on it's
more focused on the love triangle is a
romance yeah so no I'm just gonna say
probably it did real well you know and
the guy said hey you know you might want
to take your girl to go see that new cat
people
one of those kind of things yeah hey uh
would you like to come see cat people
everybody says it's great movie oh it's
supposed to be so romantic
scary okay let's go see it
that's probably what the angle was
yeah maybe and like you said maybe the
audience has responded to it in a way
that the that RKO didn't uh anticipate
the lines of ghost
remember the movie Yes with Demi Moore
yeah everything yeah yeah and Patrick
Swayze movie but skew very female but
still good for a general audience I
loved it it was a good movie I haven't
seen it a long time but I remember
really liking it yeah I think I saw it
in the theater but that was a very
female friendly
horror Romance
movie
yeah horror yeah there's a movie about
ghosts yeah I guess Connor I don't know
if I'd go so far we're gonna call it a
horror movie but yeah it's like a
thriller it's a murder mystery yeah I
call it a murder mystery maybe it's more
like a thriller when the whole thing is
about love you know love beyond the
grave so it's romance supernatural
Thriller
okay
yeah murder mystery type of deal yeah
because he's trying to like because he
got murdered because he got murdered
right yeah Swayze's character and he's
trying to like tell his girlfriends out
this because his best friend did it to
try to steal her alert that's an old
baby good movie everybody does that but
that movie did real well and yeah
because it got the female audience
involved too
but you know and that involved dudes
asking girls to come see this movie with
them oh yeah I heard that's a good movie
yeah it's interesting how nowadays like
because I kind of feel like for a long
time
um you know horror and sci-fi were more
male oriented but I think from what from
demographics I see nowadays it seems
about 50 50. yeah not back then no but
not back then it was right not back then
so that's that's my feelings of why this
movie succeeded is that they they hit a
they hit an untapped Niche yeah without
realizing without realizing it maybe the
director knew that this would be that
women would like this movie
women of the 40s yeah which that's going
to be tougher audience women of the 40s
would like this horror movie that's
probably what it was yeah maybe so yeah
it's probably like a good point but yeah
so uh if you have HBO Max and you
haven't seen it like I said if you're
really into horror you should probably
see it just because it's kind of one of
the most influential films and probably
like easily one of the best horror
movies of the 1940s uh they didn't make
a [ __ ] ton from the 1940s but it is one
of the best ones so uh check it out and
if you've seen it or if you've seen the
Remake let us know what you think about
it in the comments and we will see you
again on the next one bye
foreign